All right, let's get into hatred. Get mail
for the week. A quick reminder about hatred,
hate mail. When a professional voiceover artist
does interpretive readings of the hate mail
that I receive
because thoughts and prayers are Bulletproof.
Hey Trey at mail, written by Patriots who
hate David Pacman because America and because
freedom.
So this, this hatred mail actually bummed
me out a little bit because even though it's
completely unhinged hate, it does have an
element of eventual truth in it. Eventual
truth. I'll tell you what I mean after we
listened to it
is pack man. Ever write about anything, blah,
blah, blah. Shut up David. Just shut up. You're
always thinking wrong cause you're a liar.
You're a paid liar. David, your little whiny.
WaterWall liar. Every one is sick of you.
Losers, disgusting. I'm calling to have you
cancel and predict your show will soon be
gone from a party who's victim hoods, gas
lighting.
So listen, I mean, there have been lots of
haters who have been predicting that the David
Pakman show is on the brink of going off the
air any day. And fortunately, so far they've
been wrong and the program has been growing
rather than shrinking. And that's a great
thing. But you know, at some point some prediction
like this is going to be right, isn't it?
I mean, nothing lasts forever. If we've learned
anything, uh, from life and following politics,
where am I going with this? I don't know if
we've learned anything. It's that, uh, impermanence
is the only predictable thing in life. Um,
I guess as well as death in taxes or something
like that. So at a certain point, I, I hate
to admit it, a Patriot will write in and say,
your show is going off the air soon. Um, and
they will eventually be right.
A sad thought for us, but not today, not today.
And the best way to fight hatred, schism is
to sign up for a membership@joinedpacman.com
using the coupon code hatred at 40 you save
40% hatred. It's cry that there a flailing
attempts to destroy the show are only growing
support for the show. Um, and that coupon
code is spelled H a T R I O T for zero. It'll
save you 40% off of any membership@joinedpacman.com